on parle rarement de vos femmes à la
télé on vous parle toujours de votre foi
et je trouve ça très bien d'ailleurs
ouais j'ai publié un livre au pré aux
clercs qui s'appelle lumière et ténèbres
où vous en parler on va vous faire une
interview croyances vous êtes prêts
robert hossein est ce que vous croyez en
dieu
oui je vous croyais en jésus oui plus
facile que de conduire est elle se
croyait on s'attend évidemment je pense
oui
ceux qui ne croient pas non pas toutes
ces préoccupations mais ceux qui croient
il ya la part de dieu et il n'y a pas la
part du diable
vous avez cru comment est ce que vous
voyez comme pascal qu'avant de croire il
faut se mettre à genoux il faut prier et
que la fois viendra où est ce que la foi
vous est venue d'une façon un petit peu
surnaturel comme pas du tout surnaturel
juliette vous êtes croyant boue et toi
non pas du tout pas du tout mais c'est
d'ailleurs jeu en même temps jean vila
enfin comment dire je suis pas dans ce
camp est raté c'est croire qu'on sait
que dieu n'existe pas donc moi je
mon sentiment c'est que je sais que dieu
n'existe pas oui c'est donc le croyant
crois hélas tu essaies ou croit savoir
et c'est une situation qui est comme ça
naturel en même temps assez penny parce
qu'il n'ya pas de consolation
je vais triby normalement de cinq ans à
la silhouette triste ne pas avoir la foi
non oui mais enfin la vie doit être un
supporter non parce que vous l'avez oui
ah bon oui croire c'est comment dire
retirer son bar à la mort elham fringues
je ne peux pas je ne suis pas dans
l'état mental psychologique de retirer
son dard à la mort voilà c'est tout ce
que je peux dire
jean louis est mort flamand si je crois
je suis pas encore je voudrais le scoop
volante tout à fait à complètement
j'aime assez bien à la fois ce que je me
dis pourquoi je comprends pas vous si
vous croyez en dieu mais il dut et c'est
peut-être l'univers ouais pourquoi pas
vous en dire que les anges histoire
arrivée comme à ce que je vois les films
de spielberg d'accord ça fait encore
partie de l'univers de l'enfant vous
croyez aux fantômes way a évidemment
vous croyez pas l'heureux scop quand
même mais si c'est grave et non c'est
pas grave je vous jure que non
le croyait la météo robert non parce
qu'elle est souvent fausses samatan ça
c'est la question ultime
quel crédit croirait météo
personnellement je voyais la
réincarnation souhaite le sincère avec
vous ça ne me préoccupe pas beaucoup
j'essaie de d'exister sur cette planète
et c'est déjà pas facile alors s'il faut
commencer à réfléchir à l'arrière garde
à la réincarnation mais j'aimerais y
croire et j'aime j'aime ce thème parce
que ça crée une communauté quand même
entre tous les vivants et notamment
entre les hommes et les bêtes donc
j'imagine très souvent qu'elle dans
quelle bête et j'ai choisi déjà c'est
quoi oui c'est choisir bas j'en parle
avec mon fils les les fanges aller les
pensions laisse un peu tranquille de
l'éléphant d'afrique sont magnifiques
c'est le plus bel animal a passé toute
la mémoire du monde
est ce que vous croyez à la fidélité
dans le couple super rien et
systématique
donc c'est à mon avis je sais pas ça
dépend du couple et et je crois
simplement qu'il faut pas qu'il ya un
voleur est un imbécile ces tirs est ce
que vous croyez au sexe sans amour
évidemment c'est à dire que ces pages
c'est pas que je veux ou ne pas y croire
mais c'est une nécessité
vous rendez compte on rêve tous un
amoureux de carnelle et que verra mais
en attendant de rencontrer et moi je les
rencontrais avec ma femme donc ça va et
ce ouvriers à l'amour sans sexe robert à
l'amour des autres ou est à prendre en
charge des autres et les appels au
secours
et tout ce qu'on voit et l'humiliation
des eaux et la solitude des autres et y
croit mais alors à 100% même peut-être
que moi tu es dans un certain
progressisme et il a bien savoir avec
juliette binoche
est ce que vous croyez robert hossein
que ses meilleurs à plusieurs eh bien
écoutez moi je suis encore béotien mais
je vous fais confiance en eux c'est la
meilleure le pote de madine
jour de joie
le jeune